Writing code can
improve your workflow.
We, the people in this room
and our friends joining online,
we know this, but
writing code can also
be tricky, frustrating
and time consuming.
We also know this,
and in my experience,
it can be difficult to convince
yourself or maybe a manager
that it is worth
spending time up front
to write code for tasks
like data wrangling,
especially if there's an
existing process that's already
good enough.
So my goal today is to
demonstrate that it is worth
spending this time
upfront to write code,
because in the long run it
will save time, reduce errors
and improve the workflow.
And I'm going to use some
examples from my work,
and maybe these
will motivate you
to go off and write some code.
Or maybe you can
use these examples
to help convince a
skeptical manager
to let you write that code.
So, Hi everyone.
My name is Danielle Dempsey.
I'm a research scientist
at a small company called
the Center for Marine Applied
Research, or CMAR for short
in Nova Scotia, Canada.
CMAR coordinates this really great
coastal monitoring program
to measure ocean variables like
temperature, dissolved, oxygen
and salinity from all around
the coast of the province.
This data can be
used by scientists
to study coastal ecosystems,
industry to inform their site
selection, government to inform
their policy and management
decisions.
And the list could go on.
So this is really valuable data.
But, for several
years it was rarely
used because it was just
stored on somebody's desktop
and a myriad of
CSV and Excel files
that were really difficult
and time consuming to compile
into a useful format.
So why was this so difficult?
It has to do with how the
data are collected using
what we call sensor strings.
So a sensor string
consists of a rope
that's anchored
to the ocean floor
and suspended just below
the surface by a bouy.
There are sensors attached to
the rope at different depths
through the water
column, and these sensors
are recording data every
one minute to 1 hour.
Each sensor string is deployed
in one location for a couple
of months, up to a year.
So they're really
collecting a lot of data,
and we use three
different types of sensors
that each report the data back
in a slightly different format
like you can see on the screen.
And you can start
to appreciate how
working with this data can
be challenging, especially
because there can be seven or
more sensors on each sensor
string in each of
these data files
can be tens of
thousands of rows long.
So part of the reason that I
was hired about two years ago
was to help compile all of this
data into a nice, tidy format
that we could post online for
any interested stakeholder
to download and use
in their own analyses.
So about three weeks after
I started this new position,
I had a video call
with my manager
so she could show me how,
show me the existing process
for how this data is compiled.
And I can remember
very vividly sitting
in my home office on a
beautiful Thursday afternoon
while she showed
me this process.
And let me tell you
this involved copying.
It involved pasting.
It involved sorting the
data by a specific column,
and it even involved writing
down the Excel row numbers
to use later on in the process.
It was truly horrible
and I thought to myself,
I will never do that.
I offered to write some
code to help with this,
but my manager was a little
bit skeptical at first,
particularly because
at this point
I wasn't very confident in
my data wrangling or package
development skills.
But eventually she
gave me the thumbs up
and I wrote a package
called strings
to help automate a
lot of this process.
To be clear, the package is
named after our sensor strings
and has nothing to do
with character strings.
So this was maybe a bit
of a naive name choice,
but it's only caused one
small moment of confusion
so far.
And that's another story.
For now, I'll move
on to my first point.
Writing code will save you time.
Yes you'll have to
spend some time up front
to develop the code and you
may have some learning curves
to surmount,
particularly if you're
new to R, new to coding.
But it will be worth it.
So I spent a few weeks
developing the backbone
of the strings package.
And as I said, at
this time, I didn't
have a lot of experience
with data wrangling, package
development, working
with dates and times,
or importing and exporting
large data files.
So I spent a pretty
substantial amount
of time looking into
different packages
to help with those challenges.
And these are just
some of the packages
that I ended up working with.
You'll recognize most of them
from the tidyverse verse,
although there are a couple
from outside of that collection.
And the point I
want to make here
is that even though I hadn't
used most of these packages
before working on strings,
I now use almost all of them
and almost all of
my coding projects.
And that's because
of the time that I
spent learning about them to
work on the strings package.
So this is just
one small example
of how the skills that you learn
working on one coding project
are often really transferable
to other projects.
And in my case, the time that
I spent working on the strength
package also saved us
time for processing
that coastal monitoring
program data.
We estimate that it would have
taken two years of work hours
to compile all of that data
with the horrendous old copy
and paste method.
Instead, within a
couple of months
I had developed
the package, myself
and our student at
the time had compiled
and formatted all of the data
posted online and generated
summary reports
through R Markdown.
It's also now really
easy to train new people
to compile this data
using templates that I
wrote to go with the package.
Our current intern has
compiled 71 deployments so far
and on top of all of his other
work in just the 11 weeks
that he's been with us so far.
That's something
that would have taken
over 9 months of dedicated
work time with the old method,
and on the screen is just
a tiny, tiny snapshot
of our data.
So this is temperature
data from six deployments
or about four years from an
area called Birchy Head.
And here the temperature was
measured at 7 different depths
through the water column,
which are shown by color.
And if you're interested in
this or any other CMAR data,
feel free to find me
later this afternoon.
I'm always really
happy to talk about it.
Writing code to help
with your data wrangling
can also help find and reduce
errors in your data set.
This will give you
and your clients
more confidence in the data
and also make whatever analysis
you plan on doing with
that data more reliable.
And in my experience,
errors can kind of creep
into the data at different
points along the data pipeline,
especially wherever
humans are involved.
And so I've learned
to write code,
to anticipate and sometimes
even fix those, those errors.
I have two examples
of that for you.
For the first one,
after we had finished
compiling all that
sensor string data,
I decided to plot the latitude
and longitude of each sensor
string to get an idea of the
spatial coverage of the data.
So you can imagine my
surprise when my map
looks something like this.
So most of the sensor
strings are showing up
clustered around Nova Scotia,
which is what we would expect.
But there's also some
sensor strings showing up
way over here in
Kazakhstan, which
is not close to Nova
Scotia and not even
anywhere near the ocean.
So what's going on here?
After a little bit of
digging, I discovered
that our contractors who
actually deploy these sensor
strings have to manually
record the latitude
and longitude of each location.
And because Nova Scotia is
in the Western hemisphere,
longitude is typically
recorded as a negative value.
But every so often
it accidentally
gets entered as a
positive value, which
is what's causing some
of these sensor strings
to show up way over
there in Central Asia.
So now, when the package first
reads in this coordinate data,
I'll get a warning if any
of those longitude values
are positive.
So we can go in and
fix that mistake
before compiling
all of the data.
A kind of more insidious
error that I've seen
is data from the wrong
sensor in a file of data
that's ready to be compiled.
And this just
happens when someone
has what I call a human
moment and accidentally puts
the wrong file in the folder.
In this example, data
from one of the sensors
on the blue sensor
string has been
put in the folder
with all of the data
from sensors on the
green sensor string.
And this issue is
really twofold.
One, the data set for
the blue sensor string
will be incomplete.
And two, we will get false
information about the area
where the green sensor
string was deployed.
So this is really
a critical error
to be able to find and fix.
Luckily, the data
files are automatically
named with the serial
number of the sensor
and we keep track
of which sensors
are associated with each sensor
string in deployment logs.
And so I've written
code in the package that
will give an error if
there's any missing
extra or different
files in that folder
based on what we would
expect from the log.
Writing code to help automate
your data wrangling can also
make your workflow more
traceable and reproducible,
especially when
compared to something
like copying and pasting.
And you can explain this
to your non-coding managers
with a metaphor.
So copying and
pasting in Excel is
kind of like making
a salad from just
whatever is left in your fridge.
Most of the time it
will probably taste OK,
but eventually you
will get something
that doesn't taste quite right.
And because you have no record
of what went into that salad,
it's really hard to
tell what exactly
is making it taste
funny, and it's also
hard to avoid making the
same mistake in the future.
As my colleague said when I
was trying this metaphor out
on her, you can't take
the dressing back out
of the saddle.
In contrast, writing code is
more like writing and following
a recipe.
You can follow it step by
step to get a delicious
salad every time.
And as an added bonus, you
can even give this recipe
to a friend so they can
make their own salad
or help you make dinner.
As a more concrete
example for another part
of our coastal
monitoring program,
we had these 65
current data sets
that had to be compiled from
a kind of messy text format
into a tidier CSV format
that was easier to work with.
So I offered to write some
code to help with this,
but my managers again decided
to have a couple of people
instead copy, paste
and format in Excel.
This took hours and hours
of several people's time,
but eventually they finished.
And then we
discovered that there
had been a small mistake
in how these original text
files were exported from
the sensor software.
So all of the data needed
to be compiled again.
So this time I was asked
to write some code.
And within a few
weeks I had written
a package that automated
most of this workflow.
So now if we want to make any
other changes to this process,
we've actually made a couple.
I just need to go in, tweak
the code, press a button,
and all of this data
will be compiled
within just a few minutes.
And so if you have a
repetitive task that you've
been thinking
about automating, I
encourage you to go home
after the conference
and start writing some code.
You don't have to write
a whole package in a day.
You can start with
a function or two
and just see where
it goes from there.
And if you do get some pushback
from a skeptical manager,
remind them that writing
code will save time,
reduce errors, and
improve the workflow.
And if you do use those points
and it works, please let me
know, because it
would make my day.
And the last thing I'll say is
that my previously skeptical
manager is now totally on
board and really supportive
of all my coding.
She even sewed me this
super R because she
says that I've convinced
her that R can do anything
that we put our minds to.
So thank you and happy coding.